hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of some wild games from the
2020 chasuble masters it's a fabulous
Caruana versus yani pony and it's a it's
a game from the B group of the chest
bull masters there's a group and there's
also a big group but we're gonna cover
that some some other day and it's it's
quite the game so let's just dive
straight into it Bobby with the white
pieces opens with c4
so he goes for the English opening we
have Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and c5
now just if weif doesn't prevent it he's
hoping to go for d5 on the next move and
here Bobby allows that he goes for g3
the Karl's Bremen system and the nipple
strikes in the center with d5 we have
seek a person d5 Knight captures and
Bishop the g2 getting a reverse dragon
so tonight back to b6 and now d3 this is
all super standard stuff the main in the
mainline show nothing out of the
ordinary here Bishop to e7 and here
Bishop to e3 it's a very popular move it
looks weird as it blocks your own e5 e
pawn but at some point black will cast
I'll play rook e8 and bring the bishop
back to f8 so you will shift this Bishop
to g5 and you will be able to move your
pawn
so castles and now rook the C 1 we have
rook to e8 as we've mentioned in now
Knight to f3 Fabio makes room for
castles we have Knight to c6 and Bobby
just castles and here now to add more
defense to the pawn we have Bishop back
to f8 and now also you might be
considering some efore ideas in the
future and here we have Bishop to g5 and
this is a well known move with Lee so
played Engler and played it with a lot
of success and most commonly
well the only move ever played in this
position is f6 just blocking this bishop
however here neppo goes for Queen to d7
and it is already as a move 11 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what Fabi comes up with against this
Queen to b6 new move idea first he goes
for a three takes away the be Foursquare
from blacks pieces might be preparing
before in the future and h6 now neppo
just kicks the bishop back and then he
wants to bring his queen back to d8
which is a
natural square for the Queen so the show
back to d2 and now Queen back to the 8
now you can develop the light square
bishop so Knights the e4 by Fabi a
preparing to bring the knight over to c5
the knight will be quite the nuisance on
c5 and we have a 5 here an apple wants
to go a 4 and maybe at some point create
some sort of an outpost for his knight
unbe 3 if possible so tonight the c5 by
Fabi and just a for with the idea of
Knights to d4 however we have Queen to
c2 and now you don't really you don't
really have the option of going Knight
to d4 right away because if Knights to
d4 then just Knight captures and you've
opened up this diagonal so you can just
pick up the the b7 pawn with an attack
on the Queen not something you want to
allow so here never goes rook to e7 adds
more protection to the b7 pawn and rook
F the e1 and only now does maple go
Knights to d4 so 94 now of course you
want to capture it if the Queen moves
then you get just Knight to b3 which is
a really an awesome square and knife
capture sandy 4 so each character's and
now as you don't want to be left without
backwards epon and now Fabia advances it
finally to e4 nipple captures D
characters on e3 ALPA song and the
Bishop characters on e3 we have c6 now
not allowing this Bishop to be such a
powerful piece now yeah the c6 bone
blocks it very nicely and now Fabi goes
back Knight to e4 with Bishop to e6
finally Nippo develops his LightSquared
Bishop and Bishop the c2 you have to be
careful not to play some silly move like
Rudy want tell our Bishop to b3 but here
we have Bishop back to c5 now this is
what Bobby wanted with Knight to e4 he
wants the trade of the dark square
Bishop and then get this c5 square for
his Knight so his knife can rule there
unopposed so look back to a8 the rook is
no longer needed on the seventh rank
guarding the b7 pawn and here Fabi
trades it off Bishop captures with rook
captures and now Knight to c5 and this
is now a very strong night here
attacking both the bishop and the b7
pawn and now Nippo has to go back so
Bishop back to C SCA and the nipples
moves really remind me of out of my 4
for player chess game on Sammy's channel
against video giri and Alexandra
where I just developed the piece and
move them back all the time and it seems
to be working pretty well as here in
Nepal a Queen d7 back row k7 back a
Bishop to Bishop to e6 back and he just
brings his p6 back to net that they're
starting squares so here Fabi goes for
rook to e4 he wants to bring the rook
over you want to double up nicely on the
e-file and neppo immediately counters
that would rook the rook to e8 so rook
CTE one Fabi continues to double up and
now just captures captures so far we get
a nice outpost for his rook here and
here we have rook to a five you have to
bring the rook somehow into the game for
the moment you still can't develop your
life for Bishop as the b7 pawn hangs so
rook the a5 putting some pressure on the
night here and we have h3 not allowing a
lot of squares for Naples Bishop to be
developed and at some point you might
want to worry about your back rank if
this pawn moves then the Queen covers h7
rook to e8 could be an idea so you can't
really move the Queen away from the from
the back rank so first king to have
faith the grabbing hold of the it square
and now d4 defending the knight also
opening up this diagonal so the Queen
can also enter the dh7 square and now
Knepper goes back rocked a 8 this is a
really weird game and Fabi also goes
back rook to e1 now preparing Quinta h7
so g6 you could also go just back with
the King King Jade but nipple access
King on f8 so King so we have pawn to g6
we have Queen to d2 now we're pressuring
the h6 pawn and the King the g7 just
defending it and here Queen to f4
now again an excellent square for the
Queen and nip Oh again has to figure out
how to defend so Knights the d7 of
course he wants to remove this terrible
night on c5 as it's really causing him a
lot of problems you can't really develop
anything
and now Fabi just brings it back of
course he doesn't want to develop Knight
to e4 and here you probably should go
for something like Queen to e7 just pin
the night as the rook here is undefended
and it's a super complicated position
like it's a rapid game of course it's
impossible to calculate everything out
in a rapid game but here you could see
a lot of crazy ideas like Quintus e7u
even allow f5 to trap the night so for
example f5 now you go
h4 you don't care about the night and
after captures captures the Queen has to
move somewhere and then let's say Bishop
h3 goes after the knight here really
really strong attack for white it's very
unlikely that black will be able to
survive this with the bishop and the
rook unable to join the defense so there
are possible possibilities here however
Queen t7 is is one way to go about it
however nipple goes for rook to a5 he
wants to improve on this by first let's
say going rookie 5 maybe a5 next
followed by Queen e7 something in those
lines however wrote the a5 blunders the
game completely as well you should be
aware of that as we've reached the
position from the thumbnail so feel free
to pause the video here and win the game
for Fabi while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting the two weaknesses the f7 and
de 8 square and for those of you who
just want to enjoy a shot it's of course
Knight to d6 going for the two
weaknesses and now there's a problem you
cannot defend everything you cannot
defend against Queen captures and f7 and
against rook to e8 as the knight now
covers the 8 square so here the problem
is if Queen f6 I like getting rid of
both ideas just 98 check picks up the
Queen a very nice Royal fork and if you
go for something like well there's not
much you can go for here if you try some
like f5 to prevent Queen captures then
it's just Knight captures and c8 Queen
captures and Rookie 7 check and there's
not nothing you can do here King f8
you're gonna go rook to h7 and now there
is no defense against the both this
check which will be followed by
checkmate and also this check which will
be followed by checkmate I could also
use this for a thumbnail but I am gonna
use the other one so yeah here you
really don't have a move like if you go
for some like this or something just
captures King g8 and now Queen to g7
will be checkmate so for the lack of a
better move nepo finds a very creative
defense in Knight to f6 but now there is
another problem because fob is next
which you've all seen as you've already
found the previous move really shatters
and opposed offenses he plays rook to e8
and now that you see it now of course
you also believe it you remove the
defender of the f7 pawn and of course if
the if the rook is captured then just
captures with checking h8 and this now
is just game over
you could prolong for one more move by
defending the g7 pawn this way but now
Knight f6 and there's no defense against
both of these mates well you could give
up the Queen but that's just silly
so after this book to you move we have
Queen to d7 nipple gets the Queen out of
the way but now the bishop and see it
just Falls rook captures and c8 and
again nepo finds a very creative defense
g5 now pushing the Queen back from the
defense of the night here but father
finds Queen to d2 now attacks the rook
on a 5 that's undefended
so rook to a 6 and again now you have to
defend the night somehow a Fabi goes for
Queen to b4 but again a brilliant
defensive idea by nipple c5 now attacks
the Queen and exposes a double attack
here on the night so the characters on
c5 and here we have rook captures on d6
removing the defender of the rook here
on c8 we have see characters by Fabi and
now Queen captures here and now
Knepper did not lose a piece or anything
however Fabi does have this incredibly
strong passed pawn and he also finishes
it up nicely with Bishop captures on b7
so now it's really a a an unopposed pawn
and also fabi's fabi's just up to pawns
so here Queen captures on h3 nipa wants
to minimize the the material loss and
now comes Queen captures on a4
now it's three past points for Fabi
which will be very hard to deal with and
here if you go for something like a
knight g4 it's really not a problem for
white white just defends with Bishop g2
and the once you give one check there's
no way to continue this the bishop is
too good of a defender to to even try
anything here so after Queen a4 we have
h5 Nippon now wants the bust open the
position here and the Fabi just goes
Queen D for that pins the knight here we
have Queen to d7 blocking the pawn
attacking the bishop and Bishop goes
back to f3
we have h4 if you want to have even any
chance this year you have to open up the
white-skinned position and hope for some
tricks Shoji characters on h4 GTRs Queen
captures on h4 nipple even gives up a
point created this attack sort of and
now Queen to f5 now putting pressure on
the bishop kingi to defending and now
King to f8 and now Bobby's just up three
pawns and it's only a matter of time
however only a matter of time in a rapid
game could mean a lot of things if
you've seen the previous game gireesham
vs. and Magnus Carlsen
or rather Magnus Carlsen versus Grisha
so here a for Fabi starts pushing
pushing his past a pawn and queen g6
check by net but we have Queen the g3
blocking of course you cannot trade
Queens you are down three pawns so queen
a5 and now be for the pawns are marching
forward so 95 and here while you can
trade and as a general rule when you're
up in in material you should trade Fabi
would much rather trade Queens here then
just adjust the minor pieces so queen g4
Quinta a5 Fabio force wanting to trade
and nip of course declining and now
Queen the CA to check we have king to g7
and now we have Queen back to g4 with
check King f8 and now d7 preparing
before s d8 Queen so King e7 blocking
this and now Queen to b4 Fabi now
finally manages the trade of the Queen's
we have Queen captures Bishop captures
and Knight captures and B for now so
minimizing the the material loss however
Bishop the f5 defending it and it's up
to pawns in a minor piece endgame of
course this is completely winning so
nice the c6
and now comes king of three Fabi starts
bringing the King into the game King D 6
and now King f4 we have f6 are now not
allowing the King any of these squares
but - back to e4 now trying to trying to
give up some material here but after
captures characters and characters of
course the King and pawn endgame is
winning for white white is up upon it's
not not very mysterious what's happening
here so after Bishop b4 we have nice the
d8 and now King f5
so not much to do for Nippo here he
captures the pawn King captures an f6
and now came to d6 here we have a five
Fabi starts pushing his passport and
knights the e6 now we have a six and it
was in this position that young Pony she
resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for Fabiano Caruana
which is a shame for nip OS he started
his he is a day with a win against the
team or a job of so it would be great if
he didn't lose any games but as you know
someone said in the livestream maybe
maybe Peter sailor or Yasser someone
said that it's classic neppo starts very
strong and then you know doesn't
continue very strong but yeah here we
resigned as there is no stopping the
pawn the bishop also covers the queening
square so not much to do here you could
block in 97 87 and now after let's see
you give one check something something
you can go back but then after you Queen
that's pretty much it the phone will
Queen and it's not a problem for white
so of course in April resigns and a
great victory for Fabi so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it we're
gonna cover a few more games i-i've
already seen that one game was a really
brutal very short and that we're
definitely gonna cover it so that one is
probably coming up next I'm not gonna
spoil which one it is but I would like
to thank Manuel most burger Paul Nadler
Artem dubrovsky Nathan P light and
Walter Johnson for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos you're thinking
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chests
full masters 20/20 checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday